we're going to do this in two steps and
one of the great things is we have two
representations of numbers right but we
know that they've really say the same
thing so I should be able to do any of
these questions one way or the other and
they should both work just fine right so
let's give this a shot
I'm giving you a couple X number I'm
asking you square and then I'm asked me
to raise it to the tenth power
okay let's just try to stay in the
Cartesian well first okay Cartesian look
is that equals one plus I a squaring
things is fairly easy okay so if I say
and this is it the Cartesian way X plus
iy right by definition said spread is
going to be well plus I times one plus I
so what what I will switch okay go ahead
expand with me what are we gonna get one
plus I plus y plus I square right so
that's that's a negative one just there
so one takeaway one that disappears and
all I get left with these two I stop for
a second does it make sense to prove to
you that it makes sense let's convert
this to monarch for and then see what
happens right how am I gonna shift this
into modulus and argument right what's
um what's questions just write it this
way what's the more dos to say it's the
square root over use Pythagoras right
yeah square root of 1 squared plus 1
squared yeah you see where I've got this
no Mistral is the real part is the
imaginary part but when you square them
of course you just get that right so
using that how do I get the argument so
I can say
so you got to is really to think about
this right over here you can say sine of
theta is going to be the real part on
the models right one original and
because of is the onion is also whatever
dude right so you're getting out of that
that is radiance radiance reading for
okay which makes sense you like a k1
plus IB T good that way and that way the
same distance right so you're thinking
about something like that
there you go so now I can rewrite that
you see this I can say Z therefore this
is equal to square root of two times pi
over four plus I silently powerful yep
so now when I multiply think about it
all of these terms right what I multiply
Z squared is going to be equal to the
square root of two squared
yep because 4 plus PI over four or of
course if you wanted to rather than
adding you just double because this is
also an example of democracy okay all
right now that's what do we say I square
root to wait two and then you've got cos
PI on two plus two what's caused by two
again it's zero of course and I side by
2 sine PI 2 is just one ton Adi
okay happy now we're in more artful we
kind of might as well take advantage of
that and don't you the next result okay
because I don't particularly want to
raise this to the tenth power
okay as good as I have it binomial
theorem okay so let's do this you go now
based on this form right based on this
fall I can immediately write down that Z
to the power of 10 is going to be equal
to root 2 to the power of 10 you agree
with that times what's going to be in my
brackets cause off what
hi out four and I'm gonna and I've got
ten lots of it right that's how many
times okay so it's going to be ten lots
of pile for ya plus I sorry I guess ten
lots and PI over four
okay this is to the power half right so
to the power half to the power of ten
what happens to the palace it's 1/2
times 10 which is 5 so I happen to know
that that's 32 okay and then what angle
am I gonna get in here this is this is
now I'm gonna write it in two steps just
cancelling out the even numbers right
you're getting five PI on two but five
point two is a very large angle what am
I going to add or subtract to get back
to a principal argument to get between
now I have to do I have two multiples of
2/pi right because funky are right if I
subtract PI agar here but I want to go
all the way back but so that's going to
be I can subtract to Python this right
in other words 4 PI R 2 so this is going
to be 32 yes yes yes yeah well I didn't
used to march through here actually
okay notice like I actually just did it
as a multiplication of to no avail
okay yeah this is good right because I'm
taking advantage of something really
these prolongs on this like in the same
way that you would say I thought you
just do
doesn't every complex number supply
their bill okay now I'm almost done
right I mean in some sense as I am done
that's it monarch form I'm finished
however I might as well just because I
started off in this way I might confirm
it right now what is this number in
Cartesian form
it's give me 32 times this is 0 and this
is 1 this is also 32 I okay now hold on
we should have learned that actually
sure we write because Z to the 10 is
just Z squared to the power of 5 do you
agree with that but it's just just
powers okay so I could have done if I
wanted to
this is you know I could have taken this
result and I could have said well it's 2
I to the power of 5 which is 32 my to
the 5 and I don't either power 4 it's
just 1 right so that's 32 I as well
right so you can see I can confirm these
knots depending on which representation
that I choose which one is you know
easier for me you can see in this
particular example I probably didn't
need to appeal to modern form but the
reason why is because the number I gave
you was so nice and neat right if I gave
you something it is a little complicated
like you know 1 plus 2i that's going to
be gross surprise you're gonna have some
very awkward awkward things happening in
here the the cancellation that happened
here is not going to happen
is it right if I really have it exactly
because I was one I so that is why we
could